Have you ever wondered why people lie?
Or what is some people love sex
and others not so much?
Why does some people kill people,
but others will risk their lives
to save the life of a stranger?
Why is some people outgoing?
And why is some people shy?
Why is that you salivate
at the smell of your favorite food?
And really, why is it that we can remember
random childhood life events,
but we can't remember what
we had for breakfast this morning?
Well these are just a few of the questions
that psychologists have asked
and provided answers to over the years.
Psychology is so much more
than a therapist sitting on a couch,
talking to a person.
It's the real science behind understanding
people and their thoughts and behaviors.